Hey there, Shankar here. I'm crisscrossing the country for a series of live shows this summer. I'll be sharing seven key insights from the first decade of Hidden Brain. These ideas have made my life better. I think they'll do the same for you. Stops on what I'm calling the Perceptions Tour include Clearwater and Fort Lauderdale in Florida, Portland and Denver, Minneapolis and Chicago, Austin and Dallas, Boston, Toronto, Phoenix and more. To see if I'm coming to a city near you, please visit hiddenbrain.org slash tour. If you've heard my voice for years, it's going to be fun to come see me in person. Again, that's hiddenbrain.org slash T-O-U-R.
大家好，我是香卡。今年夏天，我正在全国各地巡回演出一系列现场脱口秀。我将分享《隐藏的大脑》开播头十年中的七个核心洞见。这些理念让我的生活变得更美好。我想它们也会对你有所帮助。我称之为“感知之旅”的行程包括佛罗里达州的克利尔沃特和劳德代尔堡、波特兰和丹佛、明尼阿波利斯和芝加哥、奥斯汀和达拉斯、波士顿、多伦多、菲尼克斯等等。想知道我是否会来到你所在的城市，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。如果你多年来一直收听我的节目，那么来现场看我一定很有趣。再次强调，网址是 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 T-O-U-R。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Human beings are wired to seek pleasure. We all want lives filled with joy, comfort, and ease. At the same time, many of us are also curious about some forms of discomfort. We go on scary rollercoaster rides, eat food so spicy it makes us cry,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹坦。人类天生就渴望追求快乐。我们都想要充满欢乐、舒适和轻松的生活。与此同时，我们中的许多人也对某种形式的不适感充满好奇。我们会去坐惊险刺激的过山车，吃辣到让人流泪的食物，
and we shriek in terror as we watch horror movies. Last week on the show, in the first part of a mini-series, we explored the attraction of some kinds of suffering. We do like pleasure, but we also like meaning, and we like struggle. We want to be moral, and all of that makes our minds a lot more interesting than if we were to simply seek out pleasure.
在看恐怖电影时吓得尖叫。上周的节目中，在我们迷你系列的 第一部分里，我们探讨了人类对某种痛苦的迷恋。我们的确喜欢快乐，但我们也喜欢意义，还喜欢挣扎。我们渴望拥有道德感，所有这一切让我们的心灵变得远比单纯追求快乐时要有趣得多。
If you missed that story, you can find it in this podcast feed. It's titled Ouch! That Feels Great. Today on the show, we explore one specific dimension of the pain pleasure continuum. Doing hard things is hard. Learning to play a musical instrument, caring for a sick child, trying to run a marathon. These things involve frustration, pain and disappointment. Unsurprisingly, if given the choice, many of us say, no thanks.
如果你错过了那一期故事，你可以在本播客的动态中找到它。它的标题是《哎哟！感觉真不错》。今天的节目中，我们将探讨痛苦与快乐连续体的一个特定维度。做困难的事情很难。学习一件乐器，照顾生病的孩子，尝试跑马拉松。这些事情都伴随着挫折、痛苦和失望。毫无疑问，如果有的选，我们中的许多人会说，不用了，谢谢。
Why that might be a mistake. This week on Hidden Brain. Have you seen those ads for vacations that tell you that all you need to do is show up? Everything after that will be taken care of. You'll just lounge by the beach or by a swimming pool. Delicious food, massages and entertainment await you. The most effort you'll have to expend is to reach for that frozen margarita or apply a little sunscreen. Sounds blissful right? Well sure, but it turns out this is not the whole story. At the University of Toronto, psychologist Michael Inslick studies the science of motivation, effort, and reward.
为什么这可能是一个错误。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。你见过那些度假广告吗？它们告诉你，你只需要出现就行了。接下来的所有事情都会被安排妥当。你只需要在海滩或游泳池边闲逛。美味的食物、按摩和娱乐活动在等着你。你需要付出的最大努力，就是伸手去拿那杯冰冻玛格丽特酒，或者涂一点防晒霜。听起来是不是很幸福？当然，但事实证明，这并不是全部。在多伦多大学，心理学家迈克尔·因斯利克研究动机、努力和回报的科学。
He's found that what we think will make us happy often does not. Michael Inslicht, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me on, Shankar. Michael, social science has managed to identify only a few so-called laws of human nature. One of these was developed a little more than a century ago. It's called the law of least effort. What is this law? This is funny because psychology, we like to say, is a young science and we don't have very many laws. I found three accounts of this law of least effort. Sometimes it's called the law of less work, sometimes the law of least
他发现，我们以为能带来快乐的事情往往并非如此。迈克尔·因斯利克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来，香卡。迈克尔，社会科学设法只确定了所谓的几条人类自然规律。其中一条是在一个多世纪前发展起来的。它被称为“最小努力法则”。这条法则是什么？这很有趣，因为心理学，我们喜欢说，是一门年轻的科学，我们没有太多的定律。我找到了关于这个最小努力法则的三个记载。有时它被称为较少工作法则，有时被称为最小，
effort, sometimes it's the principle of least effort. And 3D independent scientists discovered this. And this law suggests that all else being equal, every organism we ever tested, every animal we ever tested, prefers to work less than to work more for the same reward. So the notion that people given the choice will take the less effortful path has been shown over and over again both in real life and in psychological experiments. When we look in our own neighborhoods, for instance, we find that people routinely ignore neatly laid out streets and walking paths and instead take shortcuts I expect this must be the same on your university campus
努力法则，有时被称为最小努力原则。而且有三个独立的科学家发现了这一点。这条法则表明，在其他条件相同的情况下，我们测试过的每一个生物，我们测试过的每一个动物，都倾向于为了同样的报酬而付出较少的劳动，而不是较多的劳动。因此，人们在有选择的情况下会走阻力较小的路的观念，在现实生活和心理实验中都被一次又一次地证实了。例如，当我们观察自己的邻里时，我们会发现人们经常忽视整洁铺设的街道和人行道，而是抄近路。我预计你的大学校园里一定也是这样。
They must be neatly laid out streets and you have students cutting across the grass to take the shortest path to their classes Yes, in fact, it is a universal feature of of all parks and fields across the world and Apparently, it's not just humans that carve these paths, animals will carve these paths too. And the idea here is that even though there's a beautiful path laid out by a landscape architect, people and other animals like sheep, for example,
那儿一定有规划整洁的街道，你会看到学生们抄草坪走捷径，以便用最短的路线去上课。是的，事实上，这是全世界所有公园和草坪的一个普遍特征。显然，不仅人类会踩出这些小路，动物也会踩出这些小路。这里的核心思想是，尽管景观设计师铺设了一条美丽的小路，但人类和其他动物，比如绵羊，
they will carve out their own path with their feet connecting two spots between A and B. I remember talking to the behavioral economist Richard Thaler some time ago. He said the one rule that he's seen over and over is that people, in his words, are lazy. Given the choice, we will choose the path of least effort. And economists, in fact, have deployed this assumption to reshape the way we all save for retirement by making it automatic rather than something we have to think about.
它们会用自己的双脚开辟出连接 A 点和 B 点之间两点的小路。我记得不久前和行为经济学家理查德·塞勒交谈过。他说他一次又一次看到的一个规律是，用他的话说，人们都是懒惰的。如果有选择的话，我们会选择阻力最小的路。事实上，经济学家们已经利用这一假设，通过使储蓄自动化，而不是让我们不得不去思考的事情，来重塑我们所有人为退休储蓄的方式。
That's right. So economists, behavioral economists, famously use nudges, they use what they call choice architecture to make the virtuous option the easy option. So for example, if you struggle to save for your retirement, what about if a certain amount of money is withdrawn from your account, put into a savings account automatically without you having to lift a finger? So an interesting area where behavioral economists have discovered and have used the law of least effort to save people's lives is in the context of organ donation. So even the simple choice that people need to make about whether they should opt into organ donation,
没错。因此，经济学家、行为经济学家非常有名地使用助推，他们使用他们所谓的选择架构，让美德选项成为轻松的选项。例如，如果你很难为退休进行储蓄，那么如果一定金额的钱自动从你的账户中扣除，存入储蓄账户，而无需你动一根手指头，会怎么样呢？因此，行为经济学家发现并利用最小努力法则来拯救人们生命的另一个有趣领域是在器官捐赠的背景下。因此，甚至人们需要做出的关于是否应该选择加入器官捐赠的简单选择，
it can be made easier where the lazy route, the default is that you donate your organs, and then you need to expend effort to opt out, to not donate. Giving them the easy, the lazy, the effortless route means that more people do it and more people then donate organs later. So the appeal of working less shows up in our books and popular culture almost everywhere. There are books like the four-hour work week for example and they
也可以变得更容易，即偷懒的路线、默认选项是你捐赠器官，然后你需要付出努力去选择退出，即不捐赠。提供简单、懒惰、毫不费力的路线意味着更多的人会这样做，从而使更多的人随后捐赠器官。因此，少工作的吸引力几乎随处可见于我们的书籍和流行文化中。例如，有《每周工作四小时》这样的书籍，它们
become bestsellers because they promise we can work a few hours a week and then kick back and relax. Do you see other examples of this in the culture, Michael? Everywhere. I will never forget. I'm born and raised in Canada and I grew up with a commercial for a life insurance product that was advertising, you know, not just life insurance but also a way to save for retirement. And they called it Freedom 55. And the idea was that at 55, he saved enough. You could live a life of luxury.
之所以成为畅销书，是因为它们承诺我们可以每周只工作几个小时，然后就可以靠在躺椅上放松。迈克尔，你在文化中看到过这方面的其他例子吗？到处都是。我永远不会忘记。我在加拿大出生长大，伴随着一个关于人寿保险产品的广告长大，这个广告不仅宣传人寿保险，还宣传一种为退休存钱的方法。他们称之为“55岁自由”。其理念是，到了55岁，你已经存够了钱。你可以过上奢侈的生活。
And the commercials always had someone on the beach kicking back with a, you know, a piña colada in their hand. I remember seeing that as a child and was just in awe. I want that life. I want to have that life. So definitely people, you know, when they think about a future that's desirable, that's fun, enjoyable, it's about relaxation. It's about being lazy. It's about being at the beach and just kind of sitting. So we see this all the time.
而且广告里总是有人在海滩上靠在躺椅上，手里拿着一杯（你知道的）椰林飘香鸡尾酒。我记得我小时候看到这一幕时惊叹不已。我想要那种生活。我想要拥有那种生活。所以毫无疑问，人们（你知道的）在构想一个令人向往、有趣、享受的未来时，想的都是放松。想的是偷懒。想的是在海滩上呆着，只是坐着。所以我们一直都能看到这一点。
During the pandemic, Michael, we all heard the trend of quiet quitting and lazy girl jobs. Did you come by these memes yourself? Oh, definitely. Quiet quitting, the great resignation. The labor force was so tight that people wouldn't necessarily get fired, even if it only worked not quite to their full potential. So yeah, you saw this trend where people were not working as hard. We might say half-assed their job. And because, you know, employers didn't have many options, this was seen to be a trend, hey, you too can just, you know, have your job and not work so hard. And of course, we don't want to work so hard.
在大流行期间，迈克尔，我们都听说了“静悄悄离职”和“懒女孩工作”的潮流。你自己遇到过这些网络迷因吗？哦，绝对遇到过。静悄悄离职，大辞职潮。劳动力市场如此紧俏，以至于人们不一定会遭到解雇，哪怕他们的工作并没有完全发挥出最大潜力。所以，是的，你看到了这样一种趋势，人们工作不再那么卖力。我们甚至可以说他们对工作敷衍了事。而且因为（你知道的）雇主没有太多选择，这被视为一种潮流，嘿，你也可以（你知道的）保住工作却不用那么辛苦。当然，我们都不想那么辛苦。
We don't want to expend effort because effort is something we don't like. We are lazy. I wonder whether you've seen this in your own life. Do you see the law of least effort playing out in the choices that you make, Michael? I see it regularly. So I just returned recently from a trip to Japan and it was toward the end of our trip and One thing that I've my wife and I have wanted to experience our really our entire lives are The cherry blossoms that occur in the spring in Japan and we had a long day and and we'd seen a few blossoms already
我们不想付出努力，因为努力是我们不喜欢的东西。我们很懒。我想知道你是否在自己的生活中也看到过这一点。你看到最小努力法则在你的选择中发挥作用了吗，迈克尔？我经常看到。我最近刚从日本旅行回来，那是在我们行程快结束的时候。我和妻子一生中一直想要体验的一件事，就是日本春天的樱花。我们度过了漫长的一天，而且我们已经看过了一些樱花，
And I at that point just I just wanted to get back to the hotel room What did I want to do in the hotel room? Not much. I just wanted to relax if I want to surf the internet read the news doom scroll a little bit my wife Wisely who just loves is moved by beauty and plants and trees. She wisely decided to go to Yoyogi Park in Tokyo to witness beautiful cherry blossoms and apparently they were the most beautiful that we had seen in our entire trip and I missed it. For what? For really for nothing. I understand this also plays out when there are social occasions at hand and you have to decide whether to
当时的我只想要回酒店房间。我想在酒店房间里做什么？没多少事。我只想放松一下。如果我想上网冲浪、看新闻、刷一会儿手机的话。我那聪明的妻子，她热爱并被美丽、植物和树木所打动，她明智地决定去东京的代代木公园欣赏美丽的樱花，显然那是我们整个旅程中看到的景色最美的一次，而我却错过了。为了什么？真的可以说是为了毫无意义的事情。我了解到，当身边有社交场合，你不得不决定是否要去参加派对或聚会时，情况也是如此。
go to a party or a gathering. Yes and I should say that I'm a very extroverted person. In fact I had plans right after this to go out for beers with friends. And I find myself, despite being social, despite truly enjoying social occasions, almost invariably, I tell myself, oh, I wish I didn't have to go out tonight. I wish I could just stay in and watch, do what? Watch television, doom scroll again. I have the impetus. I had this laziness in me to like not want to go out.
是的，我应该说我是一个非常外向的人。事实上，我在这之后还计划和朋友出去喝一杯。我发现自己，尽管我很社牛，尽管我真的很享受社交场合，但几乎每一次，我都会对自己说，哦，我希望今晚不用出门。我希望自己能待在家里看电视，再刷会儿手机。我有一种冲动。我身上有这种懒惰的基因，比如不想出门。
The notion that people will choose the easiest, least effortful option seems to be a law of human nature. But as we have seen over and over again on the show, humans are endlessly complicated. When we come back, the effort paradox, why so many of us deliberately violate the law of least effort, and the curious relationship between pleasure and meaning. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
人们会选择最简单、最不费力的选项的观念，似乎是人类自然规律的一部分。但正如我们在节目中一次又一次看到的，人类有着无休止的复杂性。稍后回来，努力的悖论：为什么我们中有那么多人故意违背最小努力法则，以及快乐与意义之间奇妙的关系。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹坦。
Michael Lindslick is a psychologist at the University of Toronto who studies how we think about effort and why we often gravitate to the path of least resistance. He also looks at what happens when we choose to work hard at something. Michael, we've seen that we have a natural bias against exerting effort, a bias that is then reinforced by our culture in all kinds of ways. You point out that the unpleasantness of doing things that are hard sometimes leads us to overlook the unpleasantness of doing nothing at all? That's right.
迈克尔·林斯利克是多伦多大学的一名心理学家，他研究我们如何看待努力，以及为什么我们经常倾向于阻力最小的路径。他还研究当我们选择在某事上努力工作时会发生什么。迈克尔，我们已经看到，我们对付出努力有一种天然的偏见，这种偏见随后在各种方面被我们的文化所强化。你指出，做困难事情带来的不快，有时会导致我们忽视无所事事所带来的不快？没错。
So doing nothing leads us to feel bored. We find this experience unpleasant. And in fact, sometimes we'll do really bad things to ourselves and other people when we're bored. There's a famous experiment where people who are left in a room with nothing other than a shock machine for a few minutes, they decide to shock themselves instead of just being alone doing nothing. We ran a study, in fact, where we gave people an option exerting a little bit of effort,
因此，无所事事会导致我们感到无聊。我们发现这种体验令人不快。事实上，有时候当我们感到无聊时，我们会对自己和他人做出非常糟糕的事情。有一个著名的实验：人们被单独留在只有一台电击机器的房间里几分钟，他们宁愿电击自己，也不愿独自一人无所事事。事实上，我们做过一项研究，我们给人们一个选择：付出一点点努力，
not much effort, but a little bit, or just sit there, take a 10 second holiday and do nothing. And what we found was that it was not clear that people wanted to avoid effort all the time. In fact, people preferred exerting effort if the contrast was doing nothing at all, because doing nothing is boring and boring feels meaningless, feels purposeless, and people really don't like it. But the key to our study is that people made this choice over and over and over again, and they got to experience what the effort was like,
不需要付出太多努力，只要一点点，或者就坐在那里，度过一个10秒钟的假期，什么也不做。我们发现的是，并不清楚人们总是想要避免努力。事实上，如果对比是无所事事的话，人们更倾向于付出努力，因为无所事事很无聊，而无聊感觉毫无意义，感觉没有目标，人们真的很不喜欢这样。但我们研究的关键在于，人们一次又一次地做出这种选择，他们得以体验努力是什么感觉，
what boredom was like, and it turns out they preferred doing something than doing nothing. ["The Last Supper"] So in addition to staving off boredom, exerting effort has other benefits. What is the relationship between effort and success? There are many benefits. So, people who do this regularly experience more rewards.
无聊是什么感觉，结果证明他们更喜欢做点什么，而不是什么都不做。['《最后的晚餐》'] 因此，除了消除无聊之外，付出努力还有其他好处。努力和成功之间是什么关系？有很多好处。所以，经常这样的人会体验到更多的回报。
So for example, if you want to learn the piano, the more you practice, the more you try and do the dull, repetitive work of playing your chords, practicing your chords, the more you practice, the more you try and do the dull, repetitive work of playing your chords, practicing your chords, the better you get a piano, the more rewarding that will be to the extent that you again value piano. The more you study, the higher your grades and the maybe greater entry into various vocational opportunities will be available to you. But now this is really interesting. This is true true not just for humans. So animals that exert effort end up flourishing more. So insects, animals like penguins or fur seals, the more effort they exert to you know forage for food, to hunt for food, the healthier they are, the more
例如，如果你想学钢琴，你练习得越多，你越是努力去做弹奏和弦、练习和弦这种枯燥、重复的工作，你钢琴弹得越好，这对你的回报就越大，前提是你同样重视钢琴。你学习越努力，你的成绩就越高，你可能获得的各种职业机会也就越多。但现在这非常有趣。这不仅适用于人类。付出努力的动物最终会更繁茂。比如昆虫，像企鹅或毛皮海豹这样的动物，为了（你知道的）寻找食物、捕猎食物付出的努力越多，它们就越健康，饮食就越
varied their diet, and the more likely, the more varied their diet and the more likely they are to pass on their genes to the next generation. Ants! Ants show this as well. So there's a connection between a willingness to exert effort and the rewards that you get. So it makes sense, you know, exerting oneself makes sense, just in the sense that probabilisticallyistically you will likely get better stuff. You've looked at the relationship between exerting effort and a feeling of competence and mastery. Describe the studies that you have conducted for me,
丰富多样，而且它们的饮食越丰富多样，它们就越有可能将基因传递给下一代。蚂蚁！蚂蚁也表现出这一点。所以，愿意付出努力与你得到的回报之间存在着联系。因此这是合乎情理的，你知道的，付出努力是合乎情理的，就概率而言，你很可能会得到更好的东西。你研究过付出努力与胜任感和掌控感之间的关系。请为我描述一下你所进行的那些研究，
Michael. So what we needed to do was to kind of give people dull tasks, boring tasks even, and see if the extent to which they work on them and exert effort on them, they will feel like it was worthwhile in some way. So for example, we'll give people a four digit number and we'll have them add three to each digit of that four digit number. Boring, meaningless, yet, uh, effortful. In contrast, we'll give another
迈克尔。所以我们需要做的是，给人们一些单调的任务，甚至是无聊的任务，然后看看他们在多大程度上从事这些任务并付出努力，他们是否会觉得某种程度上这是值得的。例如，我们会给人们一个四位数，并让他们把这个四位数的每一位数字都加三。无聊、毫无意义，然而，呃，很费力。相比之下，我们会给另一个
group the same four digit number, but this time the task is not effortful. They have to add zero to that four digit number, which of course is the exact same number. They just have to remember that number and spit it back to us. Afterwards, we ask people to what extent that task was important, to what extent it was meaningful. And what we find is that people will imbue these silly, objectively meaningless tasks as being more important and more meaningful. And then afterwards, we might ask them,
群体同样的四位数，但这一次任务并不费力。他们必须给那个四位数加零，当然，加零之后还是完全相同的数字。他们只需要记住那个数字并向我们复述出来。随后，我们询问人们这项任务在多大程度上是重要的，在多大程度上是有意义的。我们发现，人们会将这些愚蠢的、客观上毫无意义的任务赋予更多的重要性，认为它们更有意义。然后接下来，我们可能会问他们，
like, what other feelings did this task generate in them? And what we found is that it led, at least in some cases, for people to feel like they're learning something, that they're mastering something, that they're kind of attaining some competence in something. And this is actually really important because one of the ingredients of feeling self-actualized is feeling like you're competent in the world, feeling like you can master certain domains. So perhaps exerting effort allows people to play with this feeling, to attain some of these feelings that you wouldn't otherwise
比如，这项任务在他们心中产生了什么其他感受？我们发现，至少在某些情况下，它让人们觉得他们在学习什么，他们在掌握什么，他们在某种程度上获得了某种能力。这其实非常重要，因为自我实现感的一个要素就是感觉自己在世界上是有能力的，感觉自己可以掌握某些领域。所以也许付出努力能让人体验这种感觉，获得一些你平时无法
get. Is this a reason why when I finish building my IKEA bookshelf, I feel prouder of the bookshelf than if I just bought a bookshelf, you know, straight off the bat? Yes, there is a reason. The reason for that is that at least after the fact, we tend to find working, exerting effort, despite it being costly, or maybe because it's costly, we find that thing to be more meaningful. We even might cherish that IKEA furniture a little bit more.
得到的感受。这就是为什么当我组装完宜家书架时，我对这个书架的自豪感会超过直接买一个现成的书架吗？是的，这是有原因的。其中的原因在于，至少在事后看来，我们往往会发现，工作、付出努力——尽管它代价高昂，或者也许正是因为它代价高昂——会让我们觉得那件事更有意义。我们甚至可能会更珍视那件宜家家具。
And there's a classic study called the IKEA effect, whereby people who are assigned to build their own little IKEA effect, whereby people who are assigned to build their own little IKEA box, they tend to value that box more. They think it's better and they demand more money for it than another box built by an expert. And what's funny about this is that I'm sure you've built some IKEA furniture in your life Shankar, and you then know that oftentimes you'll build something and hey, I've got a few extra screws here. Right? So the things we build are not perfect, they're often imperfect, yet we think they're masterpieces and we are attached
有一项经典的实验叫做“宜家效应”，即那些被分配去组装他们自己的小宜家箱子的人，往往会更看重那个箱子。他们认为它更好，并且要求更高的价格，这超过了由专家建造的另一个箱子。有趣的是，我确信你也在生活中组装过宜家家具，香卡，然后你就会知道，通常你会组装好某个东西，然后，嘿，我这里多出了好几个螺丝。对吧？所以我们建造的东西并不完美，它们通常并不完美，然而我们认为它们是杰作，并且我们对它们
to them. And part of that story might be because we've exerted effort on them and we then imbue value and meaning and purpose to it. I understand that you had one such experience years ago on a trip to Turkey, Michael. them and we then imbue value and meaning and purpose to it. I understand that you had one such experience years ago on a trip to Turkey, Michael. What did you do there and what did you end up learning about yourself? Yes, this was many, many years ago in my 20s and we went on a hike somewhere off the Mediterranean coast in beautiful, beautiful parts of Turkey. They called it the turquoise coast. And our tour guide was someone new to the job,
有着深厚的感情。这背后的部分原因可能是因为我们对它们付出了努力，然后我们赋予了它价值、意义和目的。我了解到你多年前去土耳其旅行时也有过这样的一次经历，迈克尔。对它们付出了努力，然后我们赋予了它价值、意义和目的。我了解到你多年前去土耳其旅行时也有过这样的一次经历，迈克尔。你在那里做了什么，最后你对自己有了什么了解？是的，那是很多年前，在我20多岁的时候，我们在土耳其美丽的地中海海岸附近的一个地方远足。他们称之为“绿松石海岸”。我们的导游是一个刚接手这份工作的新人，
and didn't know the route himself that well, but was an experienced hiker. So my wife and I, my girlfriend at the time, but now wife, we decided to go on this hike. We expected it to be a two to four hour hike. It ended up being like six plus hours in the burning heat. And I remember feeling it was torture. Not too much the physical strain, because okay, I could walk a few more hours.
对路线本身也不是很熟悉，但他是一位经验丰富的远足者。所以我和我的妻子（当时的女朋友，现在是妻子）决定去远足。我们预计这是一场两到四个小时的远足。结果在炎热的高温下持续了六个多小时。我记得当时感觉那就是一种折磨。倒不是说身体吃不消，因为好吧，我还可以多走几个小时。
It was more we felt like we were lost, and we felt like we didn't know where we were going. We felt like, you know, we're exerting on this effort. And I just want to be on the beach right now. I want to be sitting and relaxing. And by the end of it, we just felt mentally exhausted. But I also remember, you know, the next day at the very least, if not, like, you know, immediately after I felt like, wow, I can do that too. I too can go on a trip like this without great shoes, without great clothing,
更多的是我们觉得自己迷路了，我们觉得自己不知道要去哪里。我们觉得，你知道的，我们正在付出这种努力。我只想现在就在海滩上。我想坐下来放松一下。到了最后，我们只感到精神上精疲力竭。但我也记得，你知道的，至少在第二天，如果不是（你知道的）立即结束后，我觉得，哇，我也能做到这一点。我也能进行这样一趟旅行，没有好鞋子，没有好衣服，
without all the sun gear that I needed. And I felt like I'd learned something about myself. I'd learned that like, okay, I'm resilient. I'm a bit tougher than, you know, tougher mentally than I thought. And I felt like, okay, maybe, you know, maybe I couldn't do Survivor, but maybe I'm not quite as weak as I thought I was. Yeah, I mean, in some ways, you're learning that you have capacities inside you
没有我需要的所有防晒装备。我觉得我对自己有了更多的了解。我了解到，好吧，我是有韧性的。我的精神比我想象的要坚强一点。我觉得，好吧，也许（你知道的）我可能撑不过《幸存者》节目，但也许我并没有自己想象的那么脆弱。是的，我的意思是，在某些方面，你了解到你的内心蕴藏着各种能力，
that you actually didn't know you had before, and that has to be, you know, maybe pleasurable is the wrong word, but it is sort of deeply satisfying. It's definitely satisfying and meaningful and it was pleasurable is definitely not the right word because it was painful and physically mentally the anguish. I remember looking at my wife being like we were to kind of like oh my god what are we doing here but having gone through that that pain and that effort,
而你之前甚至不知道自己拥有这些能力，这一定，你知道的，也许“快乐”是个错误的词，但它是一种深深的满足感。这绝对是令人满足的、有意义的，而且“快乐”绝对不是正确的词，因为它伴随着痛苦，身体上和精神上的煎熬。我记得看着我的妻子，我们当时差不多就是“哦，天哪，我们在这里干什么？”，但经历了那种痛苦和努力之后，
if it was easy, if it was just a walk on the beach, we wouldn't have left that moment with any lessons whatsoever. So you've run a number of studies where you ask people to think of a number of different tasks, routine tasks that they do in their daily life, and you find there's an interesting, in some ways, distinction between the amount of pleasure and joy
如果这一切很容易，如果它只是一场在海滩上的散步，我们就不会从那一刻学到任何教训。所以你做过许多研究，在研究中你让人们思考他们日常生活中做的许多不同的任务、常规任务，你发现人们从任务中获得的快乐和喜悦的数量，与他们从这些任务中获得的意义和满足感的数量之间，存在着一个在某些方面很有趣的区别。你能谈谈这项工作吗，迈克尔？好的。所以，我们做过许多研究。我已经提到过其中一个，我们给人们这些繁重的任务，这些任务真的毫无意义，然后我们发现
that people take from tasks and the amount of meaning and satisfaction they derive from those tasks. Can you talk about this work, Michael? Yes. So, we've done a number of studies. I've already mentioned one of them, where we give people these arduous tasks that are really meaningless, and then we find find that afterwards people ascribe meaning to them.
事后人们会赋予它们意义。他们不一定觉得这很有趣，但他们确实觉得这很有意义。然后我们还做的是，我们想看看这在实际任务中表现到什么程度，而不仅仅是我们给他们的这些虚构的任务。我们做的是，我们给人们一份包含40到50种你可以做的日常事情的清单，去参加派对、报税、做作业、锻炼、随便什么，洗澡。然后我们给人们这份任务清单，接着我们询问他们这些任务通常有多费力。我们询问他们这些任务通常能带来多少快乐，能让他们感受到多少喜悦。然后我们还询问他们这些任务在多大程度上是有意义的、重要的、重大的、有目的的。我们发现的
They don't necessarily think they're fun, but they do think it's meaningful. And then we also, what we did is we want to see to what extent this plays out in real tasks, not just these made-up tasks that we give them. And what we did is we kind of gave people a list of 40 to 50 kind of everyday things you could be doing, going to a party, doing your taxes, doing your homework, working out, what have you, bathing. And then we gave people this list of tasks, and then we asked them how effortful each of these tasks are, typically. We asked them how pleasurable, how much joy they derive from each of these tasks are typically. We asked them how pleasurable, how much joy they derive from each of these tasks. And then we also asked them how meaningful, how important, how significant, how purposeful each of these tasks are. And what we found
结果非常非常有趣。我们发现，任务越费力，我们从中获得的快乐似乎就越少。但与此同时，任务越费力，我们从中获得的意义就越多。费力的任务不一定能带来快乐。所以回想我在土耳其的那次远足，那并不快乐，特别是在第六个小时的时候。但后来，我把它描述为有意义的和重要的。所以快乐和意义有时会相伴而行，但努力会将它们剥离。而且看起来，对于费力的事物，我们似乎会为它们注入意义和目的，我们拥有了那种
was very, very interesting. We found that the more effortful a task was, the less pleasure we seem to derive from it. But at the same time, the more effortful a task was, the more meaning we derive from it. Effortful tasks are not necessarily pleasurable. So remember my hike in Turkey, that was not pleasurable, especially by hour six. But later on, I described it as being meaningful and important. So joy and meaning sometimes go together, but effort breaks that apart. And it seems like effortful things, we seem to imbue them with meaning and purpose, we have this extra value that
单纯快乐的事物所不具备的额外价值。我在想，这是否能解释一些看似矛盾的数据：当我们问父母他们有多享受育儿过程时。如果你每隔几个小时问父母一次，尤其是带着幼儿的父母，“你现在过得开心吗？你现在过得开心吗？现在呢？”人们通常会说他们不是很开心，你知道的，他们在做家务，他们在帮孩子收拾残局，他们睡眠不足，他们精疲力竭，他们压力山大。但如果你反过来问人们，抚养这个孩子、照顾另一个人类对你来说有多大意义，人们报告说，
things that are merely pleasurable don't have. I'm wondering if this might explain some of the seemingly paradoxical data we get when we ask parents how much they enjoy parenting. So if you ask parents every few hours, especially parents with small children, you know, are you having a good time now? Are you having a good time now? What about now? People will often say they're not very happy, you know, they're doing chores, they're picking up after their kids, they're sleep deprived, they're exhausted, they're stressed. But then if you also ask people how meaningful is it to you that you have this child, that you're
这是一个令人难以置信的意义源泉。这里是另一件非常费力的事物的例子，它需要付出很多努力，按当下算可能并不快乐，但它具有深刻的意义。是的，绝对如此。这是一个经典的例子。所以我想有时会有一种修正主义的历史在上演，我们可能会（你知道的）通过认知失调来促使我们将育儿这项艰巨的任务描述为有意义和重要的。这可以说是我们为了某种程度上保全颜面的一种方式，可以说是为了证明那种努力是值得的。对吧？
caring for this other human being, people report reported being an incredible source of meaning and here's another example of something that's very Effortful takes a lot of effort might not be pleasurable on a moment-to-moment basis, but it's deeply meaningful Yes, absolutely. That's a classic one So I think sometimes there's a revisionist history going on where we might, you know, cognitive dissonance pushes us to describe the arduous task of parenting as being meaningful and important. And that's a way for us to kind of save faith to some extent, to kind of say that effort was worth it. Right?
所以我想有时努力与回报之间的联系可能是一种错觉。它可能是一种技巧，是我们用来让我们坚持下去的把戏，但并不总是这样，因为很多时候，随后与该努力相关的确实存在真实的回报。迈克尔，你那次土耳其之行会不会也是这样，也就是说，事实上它相当糟糕。
So I think sometimes the connection between effort and reward might be an illusion. It might be something, a trick we do to kind of keep us going, but not always, because oftentimes there actually are real rewards that are connected with that effort later. Is it possible that your trip to Turkey was also the same thing here, Michael, which is that, in fact, it was pretty horrendous.
但回想起来，认知失调基本上重塑了你对那场活动的记忆，使其变得更有意义？绝对的，我认为认知失调真是一剂猛药。我们都渴望保持一致。我本来可以在土耳其喝着迈泰鸡尾酒或亚力酒，但我却在烈日下远足。所以努力与价值之间的联系
But in retrospect, cognitive dissonance is basically reshaping your memory of the event to make it more meaningful. Absolutely, I think cognitive dissonance is a hell of a drug. I think we want to be consistent. I could have been sipping Mai Tais or Arak in Turkey, but instead I was hiking under the hot sun. So the connection between effort and value
是由多种因素决定的。我认为其中一部分有点像个把戏、一种错觉，但我也认为其中附加着真实的、重要的源泉。嗯。我想，即使它是一个把戏，或者你所说的把戏，你知道的，如果它是认知失调、事后合理化，“我简直不敢相信自己竟然撑过了那六个小时的远足。这一定是一件非常有意义和重要的事情。”就你现在的内心而言，它现在就是一件有意义的事情，而不管产生这种意义的机制是什么。绝对的。
is multiply determined. I think some of it is like a bit of a trick, an illusion, but I also think there are real sources of importance that are attached to that as well. Hmm. And I suppose even if it is a trick, or what you're calling a trick, you know, if it is cognitive dissonance, post-hoc rationalizations, you know, I can't believe I made myself go through that six-hour hike. It must have been a really meaningful and important thing. As far as your mind is concerned now, it is now a meaningful thing, regardless of the mechanism that produces that meaning. Absolutely.
这非常非常重要，因为当然，我们不断地在面临关于做什么和不做什么的选择。所以如果我现在将我在土耳其经历的那次非常艰巨和艰难的远足编码为是值得的、是有价值的。现在我的脑海中就产生了一种联系，即努力和价值是密不可分的。因此，当我接下来面临新的决策时，我会想：“是的，我认为这很难，但哦对了，努力也可以是有价值的。它也可以是很重要的。”所以我开始学到努力工作的价值，例如。作为一个大学教授，我在想，
And that's really, really important because, of course, we're constantly facing choices about what to do and what not to do. So if I've now encoded that really arduous and difficult hike that I did in Turkey as being worth it, as being valuable. Now I have a connection in my mind that effort and value go together. And so now when I make, I have a new decision to make, I'm like, yeah, I think it's difficult, but oh yeah, effort can also be valuable. It can also be important. So I start learning the value of hard work, for example. I'm wondering as a college professor,
你现在一定得应付这样一些学生，他们已经摸清了有非常简单的途径来完成作业。他们可以让 ChatGPT 或其他人工智能基本上帮他们代做作业。在某种程度上，这些系统确实非常擅长想出高质量的工作。但我认为你所讲述的故事让“学生真正让 AI 代做作业”这件事变得更加复杂了。
you must deal with students now who have figured out that there are very easy ways of completing their assignments. They can ask ChatGPT or another AI to basically help do the work for them. And at some level, it is the case that these systems are very, very good at coming up with high quality work. But I think the story that you're telling complicates what it means for the student to actually have an AI do their homework for them.
绝对的。我认为这让事情变得非常复杂。事实上，我们做过一项研究，比较了人们自己写一篇文章与提示 ChatGPT 代写一篇文章的体验。我们发现的结果，我认为相当非同寻常。我们发现他们的文章平平无奇。它们只是中等水平。我们给它们打了分。对于他们的小论文，他们得到的成绩大概在60多分离谱的高分段。然后，当我们提示 ChatGPT 来写时，ChatGPT 写出的文章要好得多，更像是80多分的水平。但随后，当我们询问这些参与者他们的体验时，自己动笔写的人发现这种体验更有意义、更重要。所以这向我表明，写文章体验的一部分
Absolutely. I think it complicates it a lot. In fact, we've run a study with comparing people's experience of writing an essay themselves versus prompting Chachibiddi to write one for them. And what we found is like, I think quite extraordinary. What we found is their essays were middling. They were on an avenue. We graded them. They got, I think, somewhere in the high 60s for their little essays. And then when they prompted Chachibadee to write, Chachibadee wrote much, much better essays, more like in the 80s. But then afterwards, when we asked these participants about their experience, people who wrote for themselves found the experience more meaningful, more important. So what this suggests to me is part of the experience of writing an essay
就是写文章的体验，是亲自动手的过程，你可能会觉得这很有意义、很重要，然后你可能会更想去做这件事，而你不仅仅是为了获得一个分数的最终目标去做它。你这样做是因为你在培养某种技能，而培养技能本身就会带来内在的奖励，就像我刚才提到的那样。这是有意义的。当你做这样一件事时，你会觉得自己在世界上是活生生的。比起简单地把它外包给机器，这有着更多的含义。所以，是的，
is the experience of writing an essay, of doing it, and you might find that meaningful and important, and then you might want to do it more, and you're not just doing it just for the end goal of getting a grade. You're doing it because you're cultivating some skill, and cultivating skill is intrinsically rewarding, as I mentioned earlier. It's meaningful. You feel like you're alive in the world when you're doing something like that. It's more to kind of just outsourcing it to a machine. So yes, it
这确实让学生们的事情变得复杂了。迈克尔，所有这些工作都存在某种悖论，不是吗？也就是说，我们竭尽全力去避免努力，去选择阻力最小的路径，但正如你以多种方式所展示的那样，做困难的事情可以带来好处。它赋予我们自豪感、意义和满足感。绝对的，几年前我和我的同事们谈到了这个悖论。我们创造了“努力悖论”这个词来描述这同一件事情。一方面，你有像理查德·塞勒这样的经济学家，以及许多其他人，
does complicate things for students. So there's something of a paradox in all of this work, isn't there Michael, which is we go to great lengths to avoid effort, to choose the path of least resistance, but as you've shown in multiple ways, doing hard things can produce benefits. It gives us pride and meaning and satisfaction. Absolutely, and a number of years ago my colleagues and I, we talked about this paradox. We coined the term the effort paradox to describe this very thing. Where on the one hand you've got economists like Richard Thaler, but many others
他们将努力视为我们需要避免的东西，或者被人们所避免的东西，并因此设计出将我们的懒惰最大化的工具和产品。但与此同时，我们一直在做需要付出努力的事情。事实上，努力似乎是做这件事唯一的意义。而且这两件事同时存在
who look at as effort as something we need to avoid, or something that people avoid, and as a result, design tools and products that maximize our laziness. But at the same time, we do things all the time that require effort. In fact, effort seems to be the only point of doing it. And it just seems odd that both of these things
似乎有点奇怪。稍后回来，一位女性对努力悖论的生动体验。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹坦。我们都有时不得不去做一些困难的事情。有时这些事情有着明确的目的。你历经多年研究生院以获得学位。你去健身房是为了变得更强壮。
exist at the same time. When we come back, one woman's vivid encounter with the effort paradox. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. We are all compelled to do difficult things from time to time. Sometimes those things serve a clear purpose. You push through years of grad school to get a degree. You go to the gym to get stronger.
你吃西兰花，尽管你讨厌西兰花，因为你知道它对你有好处。但有些事情我们去做，似乎并没有什么实际的目的。它们之所以难，纯粹是为了难而难，然而我们还是去做了。有时，我们甚至会对为了完成这些事情而不惜付出的努力感到惊讶。
You eat the broccoli, even though you hate broccoli, because you know it's good for you. But there are some things we do that don't seem to serve a practical purpose. They are hard for the sake of being hard, and yet we do them anyway. At times, we may even surprise ourselves with the lengths we'll go to
我叫玛丽·潘。我是一名家庭医学医生，在华盛顿州西雅图生活和工作。我在一次去太平洋西北地区的旅行中遇到了玛丽。她和一些同事正要去进行清晨远足，他们非常友善地让我同行。当我们穿过这座到处是泥泞的丘陵远足小径时——这里是西雅图，雨水很多——玛丽给我讲了一个故事。是的，我整个成年生活都在跑步。对我来说，这是减压、锻炼身体以及走到户外的绝佳方式。
in order to finish those things. My name's Mary Pan. I am a family medicine physician who lives and works in Seattle, Washington. I met Mary on a trip to the Pacific Northwest. She and some colleagues were going on an early morning hike and they were kind enough to let me tag along. As we made our way through the hilly hike, which was slushy in some places, it is Seattle and it rains a lot, Mary told me a story. Yes, so I've been running my whole adult life. It's a great way for me to de-stress and also get some exercise, get outside.
几年前，我想做点不同的事情。我当时正经历着生活中一段艰难的时期，因此挑战自己去尝试一些新的、不同的事情，似乎是一件不错的事情。那么你当时心里是怎么想的呢？所以我报名参加了秋季的一场能够报上的越野跑。越野跑，你知道的，就是在远足小径上跑，通常在（你知道的）我们这里的太平洋西北地区，周围有很多树木、大自然，这是人们会去远足的地方，但要在那样的小径上跑步。因此它要不平坦得多。它通常很美，但这是走进大自然、逃离城市的一种好方法。这就是它与我以前参加过的许多比赛真正不同的地方。那场越野跑是在12月。随着日期的临近，玛丽开始关注天气。比赛前一晚，她看到预报有雪。这会使跑步变得更具挑战性。
And a few years ago, I wanted to do something different. I was just going through a lot of, a difficult season in life, and so challenging myself to try something new, something different, seemed like a good thing to do. And so what did you have in mind? So I signed up in the fall for the next trail run that was available, and a trail run is, you know, on like a hiking trail, often in the middle of,
我早上醒来，看了看我位于我居住的北西雅图的窗外，发现没有雪。所以我想，好吧，太棒了，我还是要穿好衣服，穿上我的越野跑鞋，（你知道的）拿上我的手套、头带，出发穿过华盛顿湖，前往比赛的起点。然而就在我开车时，大约20分钟车程外的西雅图郊区，随着车越开越远，我意识到我看到了越来越的雪。我去了换乘停车场，班车正是在那里接载我们，
you know, around here in the Pacific Northwest, lots of trees, nature, a place where people would go hiking, but running on that path. So it's much more uneven. It's beautiful often, but it's a nice way to get out into nature, out of the city. And that's how it's really different than a lot of the races I had done previously. The trail run was in December. As the date neared, Mary began watching the weather. The night before the race, she saw that snow was forecast. This would make the run even more challenging. I woke up in the morning, looked out my window here in North
把所有的跑者送到登山口。我意识到换乘停车场有零星的积雪。我想，好吧，没关系，我还是要完成它。玛丽上了车。当她和其他跑者被送到登山口时，她怀着忐忑的心情向窗外望去。当我们向登山口移动时，
Seattle where I live, and there was no snow. So I thought, okay, great, I'm going to still bundle up, get on my trail running shoes, you know, get my gloves, headband, headed out to across Lake Washington to where the start of the race was. So as I was driving, though, about 20 minutes away to the suburb of Seattle suburb, I realized there was some more, I've seen more and more snow as I was driving. And I went to the park and ride where the shuttle bus was picking us up
西雅图是我住的地方，那里没有雪。我想着，好吧，太棒了，我还是要穿得暖和一点，穿上超背跑步鞋，你知道的，戴上手套和头带，出发穿越玉準湖到比赛起点。但是当我开车时，大约开了20分钟到西雅图的郊区，我发现随着开车，看到的雪越来越多。我去了班车接送点的偕降停车场
to take us to the, all of the runners to the trailhead. And I realized there were patches of snow at the park and ride. And I thought, okay, well, I'm just going to keep, I'm still going to do this. Mary got on the bus. As she and the other runners were taken up to the trailhead, she looked out the window with apprehension. As we're moving up to the trailhead,
然后将我们，所有的跑者送到山跨起点。我发现偕降停车场有一块块的积雪。我想着，好吧，我要继续，我还是要做这件事。玛丽上了班车。当她和其他跑者被送往山跨起点时，好急其恺地望向窗外。当我们向山跨起点移动时，
there's more and more snow. And once we get up there and I get off the shuttle bus, I realize there's several inches of snow on the ground. And I wasn't prepared for this. I'd never really run in snow. I run in the rain a lot in Seattle, but not in the snow. And the other runners, no one else seemed as concerned as I did. Some of them had brought spikes to put on the bottom of their shoes.
雪越下越大。等我们到了那里，我下班车时，发现地上积了好几英寸的雪。我对此毫无准备。我以前从没真正在雪地里跑过。我在西雅图经常在雨中跑步，但不在雪地里。其他跑步者中，似乎没有人像我那么担心。他们中的一些人带了防滑钉，可以绑在鞋底上。
Maybe they were more experienced in running in the snow, but I wasn't. But it was beautiful and I thought, I'm just gonna do this. I've got my gloves, I've got my layers, I'm gonna start the run and see where it goes. I'm wondering if some of your trepidation was because you are a doctor, and in some ways you see people coming in to the hospital
也许他们在雪地跑步方面更有经验，但我没有。但这景色很美，我想，我豁出去了。我戴了手套，穿了多层衣服，我要开始跑步，看看情况会怎么样。我想知道，你的一些顾虑是不是因为你是一名医生，在某种程度上，你看到人们来到医院
after they have, let's say, not had the best run of their lives. Could that have been part of your trepidation, Mary? I'm sure it was. I tend to be a pretty cautious person, and because I've seen so much illness and injuries in my life and in my work. And you know, I exercise a lot, but early to mid-40s, I didn't want to twist my ankle or break my leg. And as I mentioned before, trail runs are different
在他们经历了可以说是他们一生中最糟糕的一次跑步之后。这会不会是你顾虑的一部分，玛丽？我确信是的。我往往是一个相当谨慎的人，因为在我的生活和工作中，我见过了太多的疾病和伤痛。你知道的，我经常锻炼，但在40岁出头到中旬，我可不想扭伤脚踝或摔断腿。正如我之前提到的，越野跑是不同的
and they're very uneven. And so you've got to pay attention to that, even when just hiking. Did the possibility of just getting back on that shuttle bus and going back to your car occur to you? It didn't at the start. I will tell you. I had, you know, I had bought in anticipation of this race some running shoes that are more for trails but not for snow. And I had, you know, my gloves, I run with gloves in the winter regardless. But I sort of looked around too and I think my gloves, I run with gloves in the winter regardless.
而且路面非常不平坦。所以你必须注意这一点，即使只是徒步旅行时也是如此。你有没有想过坐上那班穿梭巴士回车里去？一开始我并没有这么想。我可以告诉你。你知道的，为了这次比赛，我买了一些更适合越野但并不适合雪地的跑鞋。而且我有，你知道的，我的手套，我冬天无论如何都会戴手套跑步。但我环顾四周，我想我的手套，我冬天无论如何都会戴手套跑步。
But I sort of looked around too and I think I thought, well, these people don't seem too concerned. Some of them have the similar, just running shoes, gloves, hat that I had. So I also I think thought, okay, maybe I shouldn't be too concerned either. This sounds like the classic story of peer pressure. So tell me how the race began. What happened? So I started the race, and I realized right away
但我环顾四周，我想我当时想，好吧，这些人看起来并不怎么担心。他们中的一些人有着和我一样的跑鞋、手套、帽子。所以我也在想，好吧，也许我也不用太担心。这听起来像是一个关于同辈压力的经典故事。那么告诉我比赛是怎么开始的？发生了什么？所以我开始了比赛，我立刻意识到
I was very tentative. Again, I'm not used to running on the snow. So I'm running much more slowly, I realized, than I normally would. Much more carefully, paying attention to my steps. There were hills, uneven terrain. The snow was very slushy at parts. Other parts are very icy. So I did slip a few times, but I'm with a big group at the
我非常犹豫不决。再说一次，我不习惯在雪地里跑步。所以我意识到，我跑得比平时慢得多。更加小心，注意我的每一步。有山坡，有不平整的地形。雪在某些地方非常泥泞。其他地方非常结冰。所以我确实滑倒了几次，但我正和一大群人在一起
start. We're sort of all bunched together and I start running and I think, okay, I can do this. I'm going to be slower than I thought, but I can do this. I didn't know how far I'd gone and I realized I was already soaked through. My feet were, you know, toes were numb, fingers numb, and I hit the first aid station and I don't know how far I've gone. I think, I must have gone at least, you know, six miles or more. And I asked the poor teenager there who's handing out water in these gel packs, well, how far is this? Can you tell me how far I've gone? And he asks around and he says, I think it's about 5K.
开始时。我们都挤在一起，我开始跑步，我想，好吧，我能做到。我会比想象中慢，但我能做到。我不知道自己跑了多远，我发现自己已经湿透了。我的脚，你知道的，脚趾麻木了，手指麻木了，我到了第一个医疗站，我不知道自己跑了多远。我想，我至少跑了，你知道的，六英里或更远。我问那个在那儿发水和能量胶的糟糕的青少年，嗯，这是多远？你能告诉我已经跑了多远吗？他四处打听了一下，说，我想大概是5公里。
And I am just dismayed because, you know, I've only run a little over three miles. I know it's taken me much longer. I'm already exhausted and freezing. And my muscles are aching, I think, because I'm using different muscles to balance on this snowy trail than I normally would. And again, at that point, I'm in sort of,
我感到非常沮丧，因为，你知道的，我才跑了刚过三英里多。我知道这花了我长得多的时间。我已经精疲力竭，快冻僵了。而且我的肌肉在酸痛，我想，那是因为在这个雪地小径上保持平衡，我用了比平时不同的肌肉。而且，在那个时候，我处于一种，
it's up adjacent to a neighborhood, actually. But I have a coworker who lives in that neighborhood. And he had said, hey, if you get stuck or anything, feel free to just text me and I'll come and pick you up. But I didn't stop. I grabbed my water and I thought, okay, I'll just keep going and see where this goes. And I kept going, just past that 5K mark. What was it like to run where you couldn't feel your toes?
实际上它毗邻一个居民区。但我有一个同事住在那个居民区。他曾说过，嘿，如果你被困住了或者怎么样的，随时给我发短信，我来接你。但我没有停下来。我拿了水，心想，好吧，我还是继续跑，看看情况会怎样。我继续跑，刚过完那个5公里标志。在这种连脚趾都感觉不到的地方跑步是什么感觉？
And was it just your toes or was it your feet that became numb after some time? It was my toes and most of my feet and also my fingers. I'm used to running with some cold or numb toes, but it was much more pronounced. It was both my feet and my hands were completely felt really numb. And again, I didn't feel as stable or steady on my feet. I mean, if you can't feel your toes, you can't feel your feet, that's actually quite unsafe
过了一段时间，麻木的只是你的脚趾还是你的整个脚？是我的脚趾、大部分脚还有我的手指。我习惯了在脚趾有些寒冷或麻木的情况下跑步，但这次要明显得多。我的双脚和双手都真的完全麻木了。而且，我感觉双脚没有以前那么稳当或平稳了。我的意思是，如果你感觉不到你的脚趾，你就感觉不到你的脚，这其实是非常不安全的
because how do you plant your feet? It probably is. I'm not, I don't recall how I, I mean, I guess there was maybe some sensation, if maybe just pain that I was able to do that. And there were several times where I'd slip and I'd sort of, you know, gain my balance again. And I would slow down for a little bit, and then I would speed up again when I think I
因为你怎么稳住双脚呢？可能确实如此。我记不清我是怎么做到的了，我的意思是，我想可能还有一些感觉，如果可能只是疼痛，我才能够做到这一点。有好几次我都滑倒了，然后我又，你知道的，重新恢复了平衡。我会放慢速度一会儿，然后当我感觉
gained a little more confidence. But right after every time I lost my balance and slipped, I was much more hesitant and cautious, I think, right after that. I'm wondering what thoughts went through your mind as you were doing this, Mary. What was your internal voice saying to you as you're going through this essentially half marathon from hell? going through this essentially half marathon from hell? I kept thinking,
重新获得了一点信心时，我又会加快速度。但在每次失去平衡滑倒之后，我想，紧接着我都会变得更加犹豫和谨慎。我很想知道，玛丽，当你做这件事的时候，你的脑海里闪过了什么想法。当你经历这场可以说是地狱般的半程马拉松时，你内心深处的声音在对你说什么？经历这场可以说是地狱般的半程马拉松时？我一直在想，
should I just stop? I think there were these moments of should I stop? But for the most part, I, and I realized this is just a pattern in my life, whenever I meet a challenge or I commit to something, I tend to want to finish it, to complete it, even if it's very challenging and painful. I had started it, I had committed to it, and I wanted to finish it.
我是不是该停下来？我想当时有过这样的时刻：我该停下来吗？但在大多数情况下，我——我意识到这只是我生活中的一种模式，每当我遇到挑战或承诺做某事时，我往往想要把它完成，把它坚持到底，即使它非常具有挑战性和痛苦。我已经开始了，我向之作出了承诺，我想完成它。
And it was so beautiful visually, you know? It was really a gorgeous morning on that trail in many ways, but I couldn't really enjoy it fully because my body was really in a lot of pain. Mary kept going. No matter how much pain she was in, no matter how many times she slipped, she kept hearing that voice inside her. You must finish. As she reached the back half of the race, something happened that certainly made it seem like the running guards were conspiring against her. Yeah.
而且视觉上太美了，你知道吗？在很多方面，那条小径上的早晨真的是美极了，但我无法真正充分享受它，因为我的身体确实非常痛苦。玛丽坚持跑了下去。无论她多么痛苦，无论她滑倒了多少次，她一直听到内心深处那个声音在说：你必须完成。当她跑完比赛的后半程时，发生了一件事，这无疑让人觉得跑步之神在与她作对。是的。
So I'm running up the hill. I have about two miles left in the race. And I'm noticing it's warming up. And the evergreen tree branches are heavy with snow, and I'm starting to see some of the snow drop around me. And as I'm running up this hill, one of the branches full of snow just dumps snow right over my head and all over me. And no one else is around at this point, and I exclaim and sort of let out a bit of a laugh too.
所以我正跑上山坡。比赛还剩大约两英里。我注意到天气在变暖。常青树的树枝上压满了雪，我开始看到一些雪落在我周围。正当我跑上这个山坡时，一根满是雪的树枝直接把雪倒在了我头上和我身上。此时周围没有其他人，我大叫了一声，也忍不住笑了一下。
I'm nearing the end, and it was just so ridiculous that I got soaked by this snow on the branch near the very end of the race. And at that point, I could sort of look at it and laugh at myself a little bit for even making the decision to continue on with this and the timing that I just got dumped on by the snow at the very end. It's almost as if the gods were trying to tell you something, Mary. Maybe, yes. That's true. So the rest of the race, I was able to finish the race.
我快到终点了，在比赛快结束时，被树枝上的雪弄得全身湿透，这实在是太荒谬了。在那一刻，我基本上可以释怀，并为自己竟然做出继续坚持下去的决定，以及在最后关头被雪当头泼了一身的时机，自嘲地笑了一笑。这简直就像是神明在试图告诉你什么，玛丽。也许吧，是的。确实如此。所以比赛的剩余部分，我把它跑完了。
It was warming up, so it was very slushy snow for the most part at that point, which can also be very slick to run on. And I made it to the end and felt a lot of relief and a lot of soreness. And I grabbed my hot chocolate and got on the shuttle bus and headed back to my car. I'm wondering, looking back on it, how your accomplishment of having finished this race under these very difficult circumstances circumstances in a lot of pain What did that tell you about yourself? What was the message you heard from yourself? I
当时天气正在变暖，所以大部分地方的雪都很 slushy（湿软），在上面跑步很容易滑倒。我坚持到了终点，感到如释重负，浑身酸痛。我拿了热巧克力，上了班车，回到了车里。回想起来，在那种非常艰难、伴随着巨大痛苦的情况下完成这场比赛，这向你揭示了关于你自己的什么？你从自己身上听到了什么信息？我
Think that I can do difficult things That's a core value of mine is to completing and making it through challenges and difficult experiences. This is just a core of who I am, this taking on challenges. And I was thinking of, you know, I ran hurdles when I was in middle school and my first track meet, I remember I started the race,
觉得我能够完成困难的事情。坚持到底、度过挑战和艰难的经历，这是我的核心价值观。这种迎接挑战的精神就是我的本质。我想起我初中时参加跨栏比赛，我记得比赛一开始，
ran over the first hurdle, second hurdle, hit it with my foot, fell down, was bloody, and saw all the other runners in front of me, got up and kept going. Hit the next hurdle, fell down, got up and kept going. Hit the next hurdle, kept going, finished the race. And I remember the coach came up to me after and I was only, you know, 12 years, 11, 12 years old and said, wow, Mary, I've never seen anyone, you know, finish something, you know, when they're bleeding like that.
我跑过第一个栏、第二个栏，脚撞到了栏上，摔倒了，身上流着血，看到所有其他选手都在我前面，我爬起来继续跑。撞到下一个栏，摔倒，爬起来继续跑。撞到下一个栏，继续跑，完成了比赛。我记得赛后教练走过来对我说——当时我只有12岁，11、12岁左右——他说，哇，玛丽，我从来没见过有人在流血的情况下还能把事情坚持完成。
I shared Mary's story with Michael Inslecht at the University of Toronto. I asked him what he made of it. I mean, I hear the effort paradox written all over that story. So first, she wanted to run a half marathon, which the act of running a marathon is a really, really puzzling thing if we come to think about it. We're running in a circle, more or less, and it's painful, it's not necessarily good for you. Bad on your feet, bad on your knees.
我把玛丽的故事讲给了多伦多大学的迈克尔·因斯利特（Michael Inzlicht）。我问他对此有何看法。我的意思是，我在那个故事里处处听到了“努力悖论”。首先，她想跑半程马拉松，而跑马拉松这种行为，如果我们仔细想想，其实是一件非常非常令人费解的事情。我们基本上是在绕圈跑步，而且很痛苦，它对你未必有什么好处。对你的脚不好，对你的膝盖不好。
Yet people do this regularly. And Mary, she experienced the true hardship of running. Forget about it being painful. Normally she also had snow, you know, branches with snow falling on top of her. Didn't sound like she was having a good time at all. It sounded very unpleasant. But yet afterwards, she appraised it as this important experience, this meaningful experience. And she even connected then to a story of herself running hurdles when she was younger.
然而人们却经常这样做。而玛丽，她体验到了跑步真正的艰难。暂且不谈过程有多痛苦，通常她还要面对雪，你知道的，带有积雪的树枝砸在她头上。听起来她一点也不开心。听起来非常不愉快。但事后，她却将其评价为一次重要的经历、一次有意义的经历。她甚至将这段经历与自己年轻时跨栏的故事联系了起来。
And she kind of built this story of herself as being a persistent person, a person who, you know, overcomes things. So I think, you know, these effortful situations in our life give us these like testing grounds, these testing grounds to show what we're made of. And they allow us kind of to be a hero in our own life story. And you don't get that by not running the marathon. You only get that by putting yourself in hard places, in challenging places. And that's why the economists or the psychologists who talk about the silliness of effort and how we're all lazy is not paying full attention to the rest of us and how we tell stories
她建立了一种关于自己的叙事，认为自己是一个坚韧的人，一个能够克服困难的人。所以我认为，我们生活中的这些努力的过程，为我们提供了这样的试金石，这些试金石展示了我们的特质。它们让我们在自己的人生故事中成为英雄。而如果你不跑马拉松，你就不会得到这种体验。你只有把自己置于艰难、具有挑战性的地方，才能获得这种体验。这就是为什么那些谈论努力之愚蠢、认为我们都很懒的经济学家或心理学家，没有充分关注我们其余的人，以及我们如何讲述故事
about ourselves and we want those stories to be, to some extent, a hero story. And effort allows for that, allows us to be a hero in our lives. Effort is unpleasant and painful but effort can also be rewarding. Michael and other psychologists suggest that we can help other people in our lives cultivate industriousness by offering praise when the people around us display effort, regardless of whether it achieves a goal. That's something we can do as parents.
关于我们自己，我们希望这些故事在某种程度上成为英雄的故事。而努力正是这种可能的支撑，它让我们成为生活中的英雄。努力是不愉快且痛苦的，但努力也可以是有回报的。迈克尔和其他心理学家建议，我们可以通过在身边的亲人展现出努力时给予赞扬——无论是否达成目标——来帮助他们培养勤奋的品质。这是我们作为父母可以做的事情。
To teach our children that trying is the key. We want people to be rewarded for trying. So you've got someone who just kind of participated but didn't do much. I'm not sure how much reward they need, but if they participated and they've tried and gave it their all, and who cares what the outcome is at that point? Now you're like, you tried hard and I'm going to reward you for that. So we're learning that to be industrious is rewarding, to push yourself, to try, to give it your all, to like to tolerate that feeling because it is not necessarily a pleasant feeling
来教导我们的孩子们，尝试才是关键。我们希望人们因为尝试而得到回报。所以，如果有人只是参与了但没做什么，我不确定他们需要多少奖励，但如果他们参与了，并且努力了，付出了全部，那么此时结果如何又有什么关系呢？现在你会觉得：你努力了，我要为此奖励你。所以我们正在学习，勤奋是有回报的，逼自己一把、去尝试、付出全部、去忍受那种感觉，因为这不一定是一种舒适的感觉，
and that's something that we can learn and in fact many cultures teach this we we receive all kinds of lessons about the value of trying and we can scaffold that in in in our children or our students when when they're trying for things is there any evidence that learning to be industrious in one domain transfers over to other domains? Yes, there is. In fact, there's some research that I've just done in my lab that people in fact, exerted more effort on a brand new task that they had not experienced if previously they had learned that effort is rewarding.
而这是我们可以学习的，事实上许多文化都在教导这一点。我们接受了关于尝试价值的各种教导，当我们的孩子或学生在为某些事情努力时，我们可以为他们提供这种指导。有没有任何证据表明，在一个领域学会勤奋能够迁移到其他领域呢？是的，确实有。事实上，我最近在实验室里做的一些研究表明，如果人们先前已经了解到努力是有回报的，他们在从未经历过的全新任务上，实际上会付出更多的努力。
So what I love about this idea is it suggests that we can learn to tolerate effort as a general thing. And the reason for that is because the feeling of effort is a generalized feeling. Yes, when I try hard on my piano, of course, there's something strictly attached to the piano and the finger movements and what have you, but the experience of effort is common. These feelings transfer, and then if we can learn that these feelings signal reward is coming, you then become industrious. I understand that you yourself have absorbed the lesson of your research,
所以我喜欢这个想法的原因在于，它表明我们可以学会将努力作为一种普遍的事情来忍受。原因在于，努力的感觉是一种普遍的感觉。是的，当我努力弹钢琴时，当然有些东西是严格依附于钢琴、手指动作以及诸如此类的东西的，但努力的体验是相通的。这些感觉是可以迁移的，如果我们能够了解到这些感觉预示着回报即将到来，你就会变得勤奋。我听说你自己也吸收了你研究中的教训，
and you did so many years ago, even before you had conducted the research, during a trip to Indonesia with your then-girlfriend, who again was the woman who became your wife. Tell me the story of what happened on that trip, Michael. Yes, so I'm also cognizant of, I've met lots of stories around trips. Clearly you can see that my wife and I like to travel. And Indonesia is truly one of our favorite places. And we had this is, you know, after graduate school and we spent this is I think probably
你很多年前就这么做了，甚至在进行这项研究之前，那是在一次去印度尼西亚的旅行中，和你当时的男友——哦不，那是后来成为你妻子的那位女士（注：此处原文语误或代词错乱，指代其妻子）。迈克尔，给我们讲讲那次旅行中发生的故事吧。好的，我也意识到，我有很多关于旅行的故事。很显然，你可以看出我和我妻子喜欢旅行。印度尼西亚确实是我们最喜欢的地方之一。这是在研究生毕业之后，我们花了我想大概
about two and a half months now in Southeast Asia. And at the end of our trip, we were kind of on what I call the the Paradise Island of Bali. Bali is one of my favorite places. Beautiful people, beautiful culture, beautiful nature. And my wife wanted to go to Java, which is the neighboring island just to the west of Bali, but it involved a long series of trips on boats, on various buses. I think it involved like over 24 hours of travel. And I just was tired.
在东南亚待了大约两个半月。在行程的最后，我们来到了我所谓的“天堂岛”巴厘岛。巴厘岛是我最喜欢的地方之一。那里的人民很美，文化很美，自然风光也很美。我妻子想去爪哇岛，那是巴厘岛正西边的邻近岛屿，但这意味着要乘坐一系列长途船只和各种公交车。我想那涉及到超过24小时的旅行。而我当时只是觉得累。
The idea of sitting on a bus, being bored, this is well before smartphones and entertainment on a bus. And also the heat and it's not pleasant to be on a bus for so long. I just didn't want to do it. But I decided, okay, let's just go ahead. And we then continued on to Java. We then experienced Jogjakarta, which I witnessed, you know, incredible sights there. But truly the thing that I will never forget as long as I live is the
一想到要坐在公车上，感到无聊——这可是在智能手机和公车娱乐出现很久之前的事了。还有炎热的天气，坐那么久的公车一点也不舒服。我本来不想去的。但我决定，好吧，那就走吧。于是我们继续前往爪哇。然后我们体验了日惹，我在那里看到了令人难以置信的景象。但说实话，我此生永远不会忘记的事情是，
moment I saw Mount Bromo. Mount Bromo is an active volcano on Java and I'd never seen something like this in my life. I'd never been to the moon as most people have and not been to, but the landscape was seemed like it would be you know what you'd be like on the moon. And I was surrounded by volcanoes all around me, fires kind of just coming from the ground. And it was an otherworldly experience. It was tremendous. And we spent a good 36 hours there. And I now see that the effort was so worth it to see this sight.
我看到布罗莫火山的那一刻。布罗莫火山是爪哇的一座活火山，我这辈子从未见过这样的景象。大多数人都没有去过月球，我也没有去过，但那里的风景看起来就像你在月球上一样。我周围环绕着火山，火焰仿佛直接从地表冒出来。那是一种超凡脱俗的体验。太震撼了。我们在那里呆了足足36个小时。现在我明白了，为了看到这样的景色，付出这些努力是如此值得。
And if I had not had that pain, I wouldn't have seen it. Now, of course, maybe I'm exaggerating how beautiful it was because, again, cognitive distance can play these tricks on you. But I do think that if anyone ever gets a chance to see this, this kind of otherworldly place, go. The effort was truly, truly worth it. And I do not regret that whatsoever.
如果我没有经历那些痛苦，我就不会看到它。当然，也许我把它的美丽夸大了，因为认知失调可能会对你玩这种把戏。但我确实认为，如果任何人有机会看到这个地方，这种超凡脱俗的地方，一定要去。这些努力真的是太值得了。我对此绝不后悔。
It was one of the highlights of my life to see that. Michael Inslecht is a psychologist at the University of Toronto. Michael, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. It's been a real pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hiddenin's executive editor. have access to episodes you won't hear anywhere else. To sign up, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you listen to the show via Apple Podcasts, you can sign up at apple.co.hiddenbrain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
看到那个景色是我一生的亮点之一。迈克尔·因斯利特是多伦多大学的心理学家。迈克尔，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。这真是一段美好的时光。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒公司制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·切德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。您可以收听在其他地方听不到的独家节目。要注册，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果您通过 Apple Podcasts 收听本节目，可以在 apple.co.hiddenbrain 注册。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。